vocês têm idéia do momento em que vocês
nasceram até o momento presente da sua
vida
a quantidade não que você já receberam
no mundo tem 7 bilhões de seres humanos
de sete bilhões de seres humanos 60%
desistem do sonho o seu objetivo ao
receberem esses nãos
quando eles vêem o tamanho da montanha
avalanche
a tempestade existem 30 por cento a
campo procuro uma zona de conforto
procuram se proteger da tempestade se
proteger aquele incômodo e somente 10%
atingir o cume da montanha porque sabe
dos riscos que vão ocorrer aceitam esses
riscos saem da sua zona de conforto e
usa ou não como um grande parceiro
a minha vida foi construída com tijolos
dos nãos
mas eu não aceitei
esses não imposto pela vida eu
transformei ele 100 quilômetros e venho
convertendo dia-a-dia incansavelmente em
sorriso o é
os nãos que fizeram
meu sonho pelo contrário eles fizeram ia
além além e muito além do adverso
eu me considero um ser humano milionário
porque ao longo dos meus 42 anos
eu recebi mais de um milhão de nãos
exatamente um milhão e 200 mil não é uma
média de 70 não por dia o suficiente pra
que você desista de qualquer sonho na
grande maioria da população todos nós
em média recebemos 23 novos por dia isso
desde o momento que você acorda até a
hora que você vai dormir desde dar uma
topada no pé da cama a cumprimentar
alguém na rua e não ser complementado
abril o jornal uma tv e uma notícia ruim
é 23 não em média que atacando todos os
dias e testando para que você busque
melhor conhecimento se fortaleça e vá em
frente
no dia 5 de fevereiro de 75
o primeiro não foi muito forte
eu tinha dois anos de idade meu pai era
vigia de uma empresa a minha mãe
uma faxineira ela não sabia ler e
escrever e avalancha com a vida da gente
meu pai foi assassinado trabalhando num
assalto que a empresa sofreu naquele
momento nascia um ser humano que pra mim
foi a pessoa que me trouxe a valores de
força de entusiasmo de de entrega e de
muita reinvenção a minha mãe pra mim é
como se fosse a maior poeta que eu já
conheci na vida ela tinha 10 ela tinha
nada
ela tinha escassez enorme e ela olhou
além daquele momento adverso
ela se viu com três filhos pequenos no
eu com dois anos a minha irmã edinéia
com quatro rs com seis anos
e ela ousou sonhar o sonho dela ver os
três filhos nem da universidade
ela trabalhou duro média de 15 horas por
dia e conseguiu cumprir essa missão
eu me formei em administração de
empresas
fiz pós em psicologia organizacional a
minha irmã do meio fez pedagogia e
matemática a mais velha das ciências
contábeis
a minha mãe com quando completou 50 anos
nós colocamos ela na escola aprendeu a
ler e escrever e ler de forma crítica e
ali eu cresci olhando aquela mulher e
tem um exemplo um fantástico de um ser
humano que soube se reinventar a passar
apesar de tantos nãos que foram
aparecendo na vida dela
então foi a minha grande é universidade
crescer olhando a atitude não discurso
atitude daquele ser humano fantástico
quero minha mãe meu sonho era fazer
diferença no esporte não sabe em qual
brasil nascido no país do futebol
eu também joguei futebol quando ela quer
outro no campinho de futebol de são
bernardo do campo
joguei futebol joguei vôlei fui para
quedista e depende de repente com 20
anos de idade
a corrida ela entrou na minha vida com
forma uma forma mais protagonista de uma
forma mais forte porque eu era um fã
saci wellington sena e e quando estão
sendo faleceu
os domingos ficaram vazios
quem conheceu airton sena e viu aquele
piloto atuando sabe o que estou falando
então eu escrevi uma prova de 10
quilômetros na vila prudente e ali eu vi
um ambiente da corrida um momento
descontraído o momento de alegria e onde
e testava para buscar novos desafios
ali começou um momento de transformação
de toda a minha vida da maneira como eu
olhava todo o meu cotidiano e ou
definitivamente
escolhi a corrida como a minha
ferramenta de transformação a minha
ferramenta de busca de novos e mais e
mais desafios
eu e são bernardo campo comecei a
trabalhar com 12 anos de idade vendendo
doce eu cheguei na doçaria pé de casa
silval disse que está até hoje lá e
falei pra ele que queria trabalhar
ele tem uma caixa um cheiro doce e ali
andava a cerca de 15 quilômetros diários
do meu bairro do bairro vizinho da
cidade vizinha para vender os doces e
sempre voltava não só com a caixa vazia
mas voltava com experiências com
amizades
ali nasceu o espírito de ultra
maratonista que é usar corrida não só
para seu recordista mundial o seu
primeiro ou melhor do que aquele mas sim
pra conseguir passar uma mensagem vai
conseguir se conectar com pessoas ea
ponte disso respeitar as suas diferenças
e suas particularidades
ali com 12 anos de idade eu já tinha
esse espírito de ultramaratona lista com
20 anos
ao inscrever na prova de 10 quilômetros
eu nem imaginava o tanto que a corrida
ea fazer diferença na minha vida
foram dez quilômetros prova de cinco
provas de 21
a maratona foi uma duas três quatro 40
maratonas e um dia 11 em 1997
eu descobri a ultramaratona alguém
correr 200 quilômetros e aquilo me
fascinou e eu vi uma prova em cubatão
litoral paulo
tem um grande ultramaratonista valmir
nunes um dos melhores do mundo e eu vi a
oportunidade de correr junto com esse
ultramaratonista e com outros atletas de
várias partes do mundo e eu vim e 97
fazer essa prova
fiz a prova em 10 horas e meia
cansado acabado mas a minha família toda
estava lá para me receber e eu me
apaixonei tremendamente pela corrida
depois dela veio uma prova na áfrica do
sul em 1998 e essa prova
essa prova foi divisor de águas a prova
que eu posso falar que aqui eu mais
recebi não para conseguir participar
dela na época eu trabalhava eu estudava
e eu treinava como eu fazia isso
acordava às 4 40 da manhã ea da minha
casa até a empresa correndo eu passava a
minha roupa no domingo que eu tinha que
trabalhar de camisa e gravata chegava na
empresa tomava banho das 8 às 18
trabalhadores
à noite eu ia para outra cidade
univercidade chegava em casa à meia
noite e meia noite e meia ainda tinha
trabalho de universidade
às vezes eu ia dormir uma hora e meia da
manhã do outro dia repetir a mesma
façanha todos os dias fazendo e se essa
rotina e prática do sul
eu tinha que elaborar um projeto para
mandar para as empresas
elaborei 400 propostas das 400 propostas
que eu elaborei eu recebi 400 respostas
todas não foram 400 mãos no momento está
mais entusiasmado para participar de uma
prova lá do outro lado do mundo que é um
suficiente pra conseguir não conseguir
atingir o objetivo
nesse dia eu quero receber esses não se
eu determinar uma data dia 10 de junho
de 98 essa data às onze da noite teria
que ser a data limite para conseguir
chegar lá no dia
faltando um mês para essa prova o dono
da empresa queria me dar uma carona eu
falei não
ele me ofereceu duas vezes a carona e
quando cheguei na empresa ele foi
perguntar por que eu não queria uma
carona e eu falei pra ele que eu tava me
preparando para correr na áfrica do sul
até aquele momento eu vi chacota na
empresa porque todo mundo achava que eu
não iria para a áfrica do sul e ele com
a curiosidade dele começou a perguntar
sobre a prova eu falei que requer a
prova
aí ele falou assim ah então você vai pra
ficar sul e eu vou junto
nesse dia dos 400 não há um único assim
que recebi foi da empresa que eu não
mandei proposta da empresa que eu
trabalhava de dia 10 de junho às 11 da
noite estava indo para a áfrica do sul
essa prova eu completei em 11 horas em
um minuto eu não peguei nenhuma medalha
porque você só pegaria medalha com 11
horas de prova
mas ela foi a divisória de água e
determinante para que eu estivesse aqui
hoje falando com vocês um pouco da minha
história dessa prova vieram desertos os
mais extremos do planeta eu corri na
antártida não fará no nepal na cama e
globe na ilha do sri lanka
eu circulei o mapa brasileiro inteiro
correndo cruzeiro estados unidos e fui
eleito super-humano pelo território
haitiano a minha maior medalha não é
porque não são os quilômetros que eu
percorro simplesmente para atingir
aquele metal a minha memória a medalha é
deixar um legado de educação para o meu
filho não de discurso de atitude porque
quando ele nascer
eu cruzei o brasil do oiapoque ao chuí e
bate um recorde de 9 mil km 100 dias
esses deserto num nome terceira lição só
de subir a duna mais alta a correr menos
60 graus negativos na antárdida ou 54
graus de calor no saara ou através da
ilha de madagascar cada deserto deste
cada prova dessa e trouxeram uma certeza
que pra você conseguir conquistar seu
sonho atingir seus objetivos você tem
que ter um grande porque você vencer os
nãos que a vida te oferece o cérebro vai
perguntar toda hora pra você um grande
projeto
por que você tá fazendo isso e você tem
que responder e pra isso você tem que
ter um grande porque o meu porque é
deixar um legado de educação foi meu
filho é ajudar crianças que estão em
atendimento no hospital contra a doença
grave como câncer
hoje a minha força mental
não estou na minha pernas a minha força
mental não está nu metal de uma medalha
a minha força mental está em conseguir
fazer os meus passos
uma grande força alavancadora para que
crianças que estão em tratamento no
hospital venson essa doença grave que é
o câncer
eu conheci o craque em 2008
conhecer a história das crianças e desde
então eu corro por elas eu corro para
ajudar a combater a vencer o câncer
infantil por isso eu criei uma
ferramenta no meu blog
carlos dias outra onde as pessoas
compram os quilômetros 5 obviamente e me
ajuda
há também a ajudar
aqui a vencer ea combater o câncer
infantil
muito obrigado